i want to talk about this paulina
porriskova lady the 56 year old
supermodel that dared to look her age do
you see this
i did a video on it yeah all right okay
yeah so uh pirates cover was once the
world's highest paid model but as she
hit her 50s she says she was suddenly
invisible now 56 she's leading a new
wave of older women taking their place
in the spotlight and on the catwalk and
flaunting it on instagram in her bikini
what do you think of uh
paulina porriskova carl
i think
that nature is a very cruel mistress
to women very much so
yes to women uh she's she's not overly
kind to men either to be honest but uh
the we get the better end of the deal
out of the two when we get older we do
yeah when we get older but when we're
young we don't you know it's quite rough
actually right
yeah well we're thrown into a world
where we're competing with a bunch of
men who have a bunch of advantages over
us and there's no way of getting these
advantages until a set period of time
has passed so you just sat there right
so there's literally nothing you can do
other than get your head down and get to
work yeah that's all you can do as a man
but women have got a completely reverse
dynamic and
it's kind of unfortunate actually
they're they're they're in our society
they're they're
they they emerge into a society that
doesn't warn them that this doesn't last
forever their birth
they become a woman 18 years old and you
see this all the okay cupid data and
things like that women are most
attractive two men
all men at about 21 years old like every
man will say 21 year old is the most
attractive woman i've seen the same
grass i've seen the same graphic you're
talking about yeah it's hilarious
whereas women will say you know the
man's the most attractive men will be
roughly their own age as they get older
uh and and peak at about 40 45. um and
so men men have that advantage over
women so women are given a huge amount
of social and sexual power in their
youth
that is just drained away as they age
and
this is not fair but it is a fact and so
with this is what women should be
they should be using their time in their
youth to find the
the best man for them the man they
really want uh and get him into a
long-term relationship uh preferably a
marriage so when they're in their 50s
they have the companion and they have
earned
the the status of being the wife of this
man you know this is not they're not
going to be finding themselves on their
own because at 56
men are not looking for a 56 year old
woman men who are eligible and who are
looking for a partner
do not consider 56 year olds unless
they're a significant amount older than
56. well the thing the thing that i saw
from reading that article um this polina
lady is upset because previously she
would walk into a party and everybody
would turn and look at her and she would
be the show stopper and now that's not
happening anymore and younger girls are
doing that you know the reverse is true
the guy at 18 that walks into a room no
one gives a [ __ ] about but at uh 48 when
he's the ceo of a company and he's flown
in on a private jet or he's got other
markers of status or prestige or a claim
or whatever then maybe people will so
over time the um notoriety and value and
prestige that society holds you in is
going to change yes that is that is true
the issue the main issue that i saw with
this is that
the model
was presuming that the thing which gave
her value when she was younger should
still be the thing which gives her value
when she's older and that that felt
really tragic to me because i can see
how i can see how
a girl who enters the world of modeling
who continues to be in that world who is
told that her looks are her primary
contribution to the world and this is a
woman who i think had
two or three children
um and had a husband up until only a
couple of years ago and then got
separated um
so this is someone who who's had the
opportunity to cultivate other parts of
her life are the things that she feels
she contributes to the world in a way
which genuinely makes her something that
appreciates with time that doesn't
depreciate with time and the problem is
that and this is true for guys as well i
think anybody that gets to their 30s and
is still primarily taking this their
main source of value to the world from
the way that they look
is
they have invested their resources into
a depreciating asset because over time
that is going to wane and what you need
to try and do is come up with
grace
poise
interest humor yeah all of those things
right these things are going to
appreciate with time these are these are
the things that you can have on your 70
and still crush a room with you know you
can have comedians uh you know your
granddad you don't think about you
you're not bothered about your granddad
walking into a room because he's like
the best looking guy in the room but he
might be the one that's got the most
virtue or wisdom or insight or humor or
balance or whatever it might be
and there's a lie that's sold
from
the media and from consumerist society
that the primary value that women have
isn't even their beauty it's their
hotness
if you look at the sort of women that we
see
on tv on love island i'm aware that i'm
chilling for this as well um but the the
girls that go on there
not that they're not always so part of
your wisdom don't apologize true uh
not that they're not always they're not
ever beautiful but they're often hotter
than they are beautiful
that's being signaled off of very very
immediate hotness as opposed to timeless
beauty which i think because i mean you
could you could be beautiful in a in a
very conservative dress you know but you
can't be hot in a very conservative
dress you know that's what you're saying
right yeah but but you you i i think
you've i think you're making a great
point and the like it's very rare for
men to be able to leverage their
attractiveness uh to any significant
degree like you know that's a very very
small percentage of men who become like
you know famous actors or something in
their 20s and then get you know any
woman in the world that's chris
dicaprio's of the world yeah it's
probably not going to be you right so
what you you're probably about five out
of ten like you know like me uh and you
know most women are going to be about
five out of ten but women are more
attractive as they're young and grow
less attractive as they get old and men
are less attractive as the young and
grow more attractive as their world and
this is just the way that nature plays
the game exactly as you were describing
it um but the and it is exactly as you
say like society is not preparing women
to learn
that i mean i can't even imagine what it
must have been like to be 21 years old
and literally have the world at your
feet you know and i think most men have
no idea what that experience is going to
be like because i was nobody of any
importance and nobody cared about you
know me in any particular way apart from
my friends and family of course you know
no i was not in any way impressive or
important when i was 21 years old unlike
this model who was getting you know
millions of dollars per contract and who
was commanding the room and who's the
very top of society you know and so to
just have that you know just just slowly
fade away until no one cares about me
it's like well yeah but you
essentially were given a gift when you
were young and you didn't as you say
cultivate anything else you thought well
i've got this one thing i don't need to
do anything else whereas i've had to
have this slow laborious and often
depressing ascent to a position where
people actually give you what i have to
say you know and people actually care
whether i'm i'm you know i say this or
that or anything and it's it's a very
privileged place to be but i've worked
really hard for it you know and it's
it's not something can just be taken
away by you know my my growing older
unless i go totally seen out of course
but then i think i've got other problems
at that point um you know it's it's
something that and i i can it's a it's
this this thing that i can continue to
cultivate that will continue to get
better whereas she's out of options now
you know she can't do that and we don't
prepare women for this inevitability it
is inevitable that you will get old
you'll become saggy you will get wrinkly
and you'll become infertile and then men
will not be interested in you so if you
base your success off the interest of
the opposite sex that's eventually going
to stop and you need to be prepared for
that and most most thrall of human
history every civilization knew this and
accepted this as part of the sort of
teleology of being a woman this is
what's going to happen so we and we had
social roles for women to fall into you
know to grow into after the the beauty
had
faded somewhat you know you'd be married
you'd be a pillar of the community you'd
be involved in some sort of social club
or you know a charity you'd be doing
something you and then you you go to a
mother and then to a grandmother and so
now you're you know as an older woman
you still have plenty of value to your
children and your grandchildren there
are still people who care about you and
don't run this other woman has children
and doubtless have grandchildren so she
she at least still has that life path
open but a lot of women these days are
not having children but even even even
the conversation that she brings up
there she doesn't say
she doesn't mention them does she
precisely no it's weird isn't it because
you think she'd take solace in the fact
that she at least has a family who love
her you know but she's uh trying to gain
the attention of men like she did when
she was in her 20s it's like that period
of your life is over you need to come to
terms with that because it's kind of
embarrassing granny that you're posting
bikini shots on instagram like what are
you doing i don't want my grandmothers
to be doing that i want them to have a
bit of dignity and self-respect and to
to grow into the role that nature has
expected of you you know because you
can't avoid it
as she's found out to her chagrin and
you're going to be you're going to be
defeated by someone who is
30 years younger than you now which she
complains about in the article there's
no getting around it but she was more
than happy to take the success of that
when she was beating the 56 year olds
when she was 21. yeah i you know i i'm
very very sort of not cautious but it is
it is sort of uh
cautious of trying to be sympathetic to
the situation that
women have got themselves to that place
perhaps and they didn't know if she'd
known when she was 21 that if i'd
continue down this road when i'm 50 by
the time i'm 56 i'm going to be
miserable she probably would have done
things differently so partly you think
well you know you're culpable to some
extent but also nobody warned you and i
think it is important to to try and have
these warnings out there for women i i'm
i'm actually a bit more sympathetic than
that because i do think that
you are a product of your environment to
a great degree and if you're in an
environment that that venerates youth
and
doesn't have any
time or consideration for
wisdom and age then you end up in a
position where you just don't have
anyone point putting that in your mind
you know that's just not a thought that
you ever have and there's no reason for
you to have had it you know and so it's
it's kind of cruel frankly what i think
our society does to women um as they
grow older and you're getting out you're
getting now loads of millennial
wine aunts who are getting into their
40s and i i do these segments on the
podcast all the time because whenever
you know in whatever vogue or bustle or
whatever the women's magazine is where
it's i'm 40 years old i have three
degrees i earn 100 000
dollars a year i've got two cats and i
can't find a man what's going on
who told you that you would be able to
find a man with those credentials you
know why would you think you're in your
40s you'd start settling down and
finding a husband and kids it's not good
for either
generally no it's not good for men
it's not good for men because there is a
group of career women who are chasing
education employment and status
throughout their 20s and 30s which means
that they're unavailable and then by the
time that they do get there most women
don't want to be in a relationship with
a man that earns less than them and is
less uh educated which means that
they've competed themselves out of their
own dominance hierarchy because there's
no one above and across the men that
they're looking for are around their age
but the men that are around their age
are looking for women that are 10 years
10 years younger than them yeah and also
the dating pool is very narrow at that
point you know very very narrow and and
but it's it's more than that as well
though because think about what they're
doing in the process of coming up to
that point where they're like uh you
know i i can't find a man and why isn't
society paying attention i and i i hear
the word invisible being used a lot by
these women uh this is a constant and
multiple times she uses it in that
article and i've seen other in other
places it's like i'm invisible and it's
like yeah you're like me
i'm invisible like i just walk around
and get on with my life i don't have
like women like looking at me and you
probably do but i i don't have women's
looking at me as i go past you know
this is what life is like um but the the
the sort of like
not necessarily the model obviously
because she's not competing in an arena
where men would also be competing but
the the four-year-old wine aunt who's
the you know the deputy ceo of a company
or something
her working in the corporate world is
her occupying a position that a man
could have been occupying and so she's
knocking men a man down on that sort of
social scale and so when you've got
millions of women in the workplace all
like being girl bosses well you're
generally innovating the status of men
in society you think okay well you know
men deserve it i don't care i'm a
feminist it's like sure sure yeah
but that's my point you're elevating the
level of men in society for your own
personal gain getting to the pinnacle
and then being like i'm lonely where are
all the good men at yeah i'm lonely
where are all the good men i can't find
a man it's like yeah well you were
selfish you didn't consider what men
need to be attractive to you let alone
for their own self-esteem and for their
own vitality and prosperity you were
just like me me me me me and then you're
still me me me me i know and all these
guys have just checked out society
they're just you know playing their
xboxes living in shared accommodation
with each other until they're well into
their late 30s drinking beer every night
and working crappy jobs and they're fine
you know because they actually don't
need much to get along but i think if
you asked any of them they would say
yeah i would like a wife you know i
would like a family i would like it i
would like a successful career i would
like to have the prestige of being the
breadwinner in the household you know
it's not that i'm saying women can't
work or anything like that but like
be considerate where's the good will
from either side you know and it seems
to be the lack of goodwill on the part
of the career woman has just
ruined the way our civilization works
and it's not good for the men it's not
good for the women and the results of
this are smacking us in the faces right
now there's nothing we can do about it
now what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace